if everyone can please find your seats
quickly we're ready to start the
afternoon session in the first part is
my Austria Fisher from the University of
Bonn hello everyone I just moved to
university bow home two weeks ago seems
a lot to the organizers for the
invitation and you had a bit about deep
learning already and artificial in your
networks of course there are really
simple models of their biological
counterparts and so I think it's a
really interesting approach to design
new learning mechanisms or architectures
by asking if we can let us expire by
expires by the learning mechanisms of
the brain on the one hand of course from
the view of a machine owner with a hope
to develop more efficient learning
algorithms but also on the other hand
because it might lead to new insights on
the field of neuroscience so I could
also have put a picture like was
two-sided arrow or a circle but in
neuroscience and machine learning and
things I want to present today based on
the work I did and really my postdoc um
it's a mantra Institute of learning
algorithms together with Yasha Benji
Tamar and I Ching Tony and Benjamin and
the project came up by thinking about if
we can find more biologically plausible
learning algorithms that could be
applied to deep learning algorithms so I
see most of the audience now about
deepening networks and how the learning
work where but I will really fastly
cover it to give the motivation so the
simple networks we use in that efficient
your networks or simple neural models we
use their address these weighted sum of
inputs which are then input it into some
nonlinear activation function and we can
take these simple neurons to build
bigger networks where we in a supervised
setting have some inputs some hidden
neurons to compute in the middle and
then some output neurons that should
output
mapping or the output corresponding to
the inputs that we want to learn and
then mapping from input to output
variables from Mathematica views is the
network suggest a very nested function
where we always internet between
alternate between wait matrices and
non-linear activation functions and
learning just standby stochastic
gradient decent so we look at the error
the network does and sees this error as
a function of the parameters and then
calculates a gradient with best
practices parameters and adapts shifter
weights what parameters are bitten due
to the negative direction of the
gradient
this is stochastic gradient descent
given as this formula and the algorithm
used to calculate the gradient it's just
[Music]
called back propagation we heard this
before and where we usually have one
feed forward pass and the new network
calculating the output based on the
output we calculate the error and then
there's a perform the back pass where we
calculate the gradients with respect to
the parameters of one layer taking the
well use we start on the feed forward
path and the gradients we calculated for
the previous layer so we always have
ceased by donating between a feed
forward pass and backward pairs and of
course this is not really plausible from
a biological perspective for several
reasons but except like most of all
because we don't believe that it's very
plausible that we have two kinds of
calculations or neural computations one
for calculating the prediction or
performing the inference and one for
calculating a gradient and propagating
it backwards so on the long way to reach
finally biological plausible models we
did a small step by introducing this
framework which where the neural
computation corresponds to both the
inference and prediction making and the
error back propagation and which has
also the nice property that the weight
updates correspond to spike
timing-dependent plasticity which is
observed
yeah and the brain and the learning
processes but at least in some so the
other half of my talk is following I
want to introduce our energy based model
framework and where we have halves the
approximation of back propagation and
then I want to go to the link to STP so
let's look at a different kind of newer
models and that that we saw before on
your update model so let's consider a
vector as T here at some time T which
carries the whole network so so single
elements of this vector would be the
state of single neurons which from a
biological plausible of biological view
could could be correspond to time and
again to integrated voltage voltage
potential and then we would get an
update of these neurons and so we get a
new state of the neurons based on this
function R which can be seen as a
function that takes the current state of
the neuron and outputs a new state for
our neurons which was based on the
neighboring states so output some kind
of target state this difference here's
an would be the direction of the current
state and the target state and we would
shift the current state a bit in this
direction with a small epsilon e here we
could also include some noise for
example a sample from a Gaussian with
zero mean in this model to take into
account that and all these spiking
effects of neurons I have some random
effects
so if we now look at this like yeah
continuous counterparties discrete
update formulas could would correspond
to the following differential equation
which is the integrator a leaky
integrator and your model which is used
in computational neuroscience so this is
a nice property with it can be seen as a
discrete version of C sleek integrator
model now let's assume that as a whole
model as a whole system
it's a probabilistic graphical model and
under active probabilistic graphical
model which means that the probability
distribution over all states that the
system could take would be given by
these gifts distribution so each of the
power of minus some energy function of
the states and let's further assume
that's the update direction that we take
so this target state minus the current
state that we saw before that this
update Direction is proportional to the
logarithm log probability gradient with
respect to the states or equivalently
minus the energy gradients with respect
to the states and this would mean that
if we update a neuron in this direction
we would move the state of the neurons a
bit to the direction of getting more
probable States and if we look more
carefully to it we can see like you can
write as told that you denote the noisy
state to get a bit easier an annotation
here so this is again the same update
formula that we saw before we subtract
the net noisy state then this exactly
gets with our assumption that negative
energy gradient and what is left from
here we have stress the noise term and
we can rewrite now all states in the
terms of the noisy States so this is
noise the state - the noise we do the
same here and then called reorder terms
and then we get something that looks
like this and this is interesting from a
mathematical point of view because what
we see
that we have our and oh yeah new state
is given by the old state which is shift
it is a bit in the direction of the
negative energy gradient and then we
have add some noise terms and that is
exactly what is done when performing a
Markov chain Monte Carlo or Joe veeneman
Markov chain Monte Carlo inference where
usually there needs to be an additional
acceptance step so it's not really
mathematical super-clean but it shows us
that this Malik integrator neurons
perform some kind of probabilistic
inference that lead us to reach a more
probable probable States which is really
nice because I'm it was often assumed
that and maybe inference in the brain
corresponds to moving somehow to more
probable States and the some kind of
probability distribution and so so in
the sense in terms that they increase
and coherence between an external signal
and the internal representation of
signal so you started off with back
propagation as sort of the thing that
you want to change every place you went
to a graphical representation so with
the idea P V that you have the input you
have a target output in this graphical
model and he wants so and you have
changed the formula so from the gradient
descent or rectification to this
graphical model representation in order
to make the mathematics more tractable
because if distributions and you can
work with an energy function but still
you're actually solving the same problem
but sort of in a pro basic framework
idea yeah the idea to move to the
probabilistic framework but we will see
in the end that um in this probabilistic
framework interestingly some of the
problems or propagations or new updates
correspond to back propagation in the
end so this is where we will end up in
the end so but up until now we just saw
that we can look at it
one kind of new update which is like the
dick integrator Network and that we can
interpret the whole system as a
probabilistic model what gets lost or
what gets changed compared to the back
propagation so now if you make these
assumptions maybe we can talk about
later because we will see like we will
come back to the back for vocation
connection
soonish so now we we made this
assumption that we had these update
direction is equal to the greater like
local energy gradient and we won't I
want to show that it is not a like a big
assumption because we can just for
example look at the following energy
function which is really like really
closely related to the hot fluid model
or the energy function used and
restricted Boltzmann machines so we
would have here's W IJ would be the
weight between some unit I and J and we
have some function Rho which can is a
some non area monotonic function between
0 and 1 which could from a biological
you seen as be seen as a function that
plots the activation of the neuron to a
firing rate so we would have this sum of
all neighboring units weighted by whites
something like a bias term for
measurement and for machining
perspective and the nice thing is here
if we assume that the connection form or
the weight between a and J and J and I
is the same which of course it's not
super logical plausible to we get a
energy derivative of this energy
function with respect to the states it's
just given by this formula and we can
see that we have one part which looks
like the information given weighted
information or firing rate from the
neighboring neurons and we have a part
which is the old state so we have
exactly what we did as an exemption
having that the energy gradient is
exactly given by some function which
could be seen as the input from the
surrounding neurons and the old - the
old state
so now one can I could wonder what what
if we have such a system what's the
equilibria of the systems are like if we
run a LED system run
what happened since a long time of
course in the if we would ignore the
noise and if you have a deterministic
system we would end up with fixed points
where the energy gradient is zero so the
new state that would be suppose the
target state would be exactly the same
state and the network wouldn't move so
we would converge to some kind of sister
fixed point if we would go into this to
has the case we just saw that the
updates approximately run a same kind of
laws of in Markov chain so we would
approximately converge to the station
distribution of that Markov chain and
but we will focus now for under student
deterministic case because it makes
things a bit easier now we now we get to
the learning part to go to learning we
need to move a bit more to the
supervised machine learning scenario so
we need to distinguish between
observable and not an observable units
so we have let's the trick distinguish
but in our system between some input
variable X and some output variable Y
and some hidden variables this could be
arbitrary all right but let's for
simplicity let's focus to the standard
layered system here then we could
imagine that we have a extra like some
external state that that we would like
to model so this is a target state we
would like our variable Y or unit Y to
output exactly this state D so if we
would like to do perform inference in
such a system we would clamp these and
visible observable variables or external
s demos and then and perform inference
less the system settle to a fixed point
see what m it output it puts here at Y
and hope that it's close to D otherwise
we need to change the parameters of the
system
so let's assume now that we are not out
putting the white target and we shifting
the parameters or the statewide a bit in
the direction of the variable we let we
have let our network settle to some
fixed point and then we got is y is zero
now because it's a time zero as our
prediction we shift now we could measure
this how much the output differs from
other target by this squared mean and
then we could change our in the first
step change these output variables a bit
in the direction of the target so this
would correspond to one step of gradient
descent with respect to this error
function now we could ask what happens
to the rest of the system now that we
moved the output variables a bit because
now we are not in the fixed point
anymore and we could ask how is this
influence since the rest of the system
and so we can locate like this h LS now
is the highest hidden layer which was
not changed in the first the first time
step which just changed the output
variables a bit so they state the hidden
variable state in the and the fixed
point this dress the aptoide rule we
have here the the fixed point slightly
adapted in the or shifted in the
direction of Delta Y and the output
variables and we still have h 0 here
because of the first time steps they
didn't changed and we have now an index
age here because we are not only
interested in the usually hours that the
function that output it all new state
for all the variables in the network but
now we are only interested in the
variables that we output for the highest
hidden layer if we now make a Taylor
approximation of this function R in the
fixed point
something interesting happens because
the first time the first term first
order term would be exactly h0 so this
vanishes with canceled I was Moses and
the second approximation we only have
the change in Y so we only need to take
into account the Y terms which would be
the derivative of R - y and x used data
Y and thence we have some higher order
terms which we can ignore in the setting
of a layered system because they're
exactly zero there so I will ignore them
from one now on and now we can make use
of the fact that we that we saw before
that the our function R is just the
derivative of some energy function well
the main thing is here that it's a
derivative of some function because we
want to make use of the symmetry of
second order derivatives or second
derivatives so because we look at this
part now we have it here and we have
feel R for the output variables a H and
the index it means it was an energy
function derivative with respect to H
and we take a derivative to Y now so we
can also change it to take the
derivative of our 2y and then the
derivative to H this is nice because the
[Music]
the fixed point this term is exactly
again given by y 0 so everything
collapses and we have the derivative of
the loss function with respect to the
parameters and here it comes the
connection to a back propagation so if
we start in such an energy-based system
form on fixed point and look at the
first steps of neural computation they
exactly resemble back propagation except
from this small term epsilon and we
could continue this kind of arguments in
the next time step and would see that in
each time step the perturbations would
reach another layer and every time this
these Federation's would look like the
derivative of the loss with respect to
the parameters of the layer so we have a
system that at least in the first steps
of iteration starting from fixed point
have a newer computation that back
propagates the error this also works and
other kind of networks but this is a
yeah it's like to make it easier and to
get rid of these second order terms or
third order terms in as a Taylor
approximation we need a layered system
yeah that's not so it looks like a
plausible if the weights are not
symmetric I mean would they become
symmetric through the dynamics and I
think I think we didn't try that it
could be a hope I think there's some
work of chemistry that indicates that
some whites can get our pH be symmetric
but you know like if we have started
with this undirected model we have
course F like undirected weights and
undirected links so it would be unlike
naturally or to have these symmetric
words directed model and then the
dynamics would just sort of naturally
need to symmetric grades I mean so that
you don't need it as an assumption could
be a result of the dynamics so now we
come to the link to spike time-dependent
assisity
so what was back propagated up until now
was a gradient with respect to the state
of the network's Legation happens sort
of sign ups by now silence or layer by
layer in the time
in time step so network you need five
time steps to propagate you avoid this
sort of implausible sort of going back
and forth of the derivatives exactly and
you wouldn't have like a other kind of
calculation like calculating the
gradient directly back propagating this
gradient exactly automatically comes up
as this new update not lost like the
last function would be the difference to
the target like between the output of
the network and the target like standard
mean squared error or something yes a
loss was like just measuring the
difference between the output of the
network and the target and the energy is
as a function that describes a
probability function or a probability
distribution over the states for a given
set of weights for our given set of
weights right no we're not optimizing
with the loss function the probability
distribution so but average now we saw
how is it as it's a gradient with
respect to the states is perfect
propagated similar to back propagation
but we down didn't saw how we can use
this signal to update the weights what
we need to do for learning and the nice
thing is about I will talk now about
these right updates and say that they
resemble spike timing-dependent
plasticity so that's what we seem so far
the updates of hidden neurons is
proportional to the loss or gradient
loss loss gradient and so let's now look
at a certain white which connects some
postsynaptic neuron I and lower layer
neuron Dre
and we could if we regret see thanks the
state of the postsynaptic neuron as a
faction of the waves we could apply the
chain rule like it's usually done and
say that the weight update should be
given by the update of the hidden
neurons and then the derivative of the
hidden neurons with respect to the white
weight so if we saw before that we have
this kind of from the energy function
stemming new update of the state and if
we take the derivative of this with
respect to the whites we just end up
with yeah this multiplied by H J so we
go back here now and in the old general
notation where we noted all variables by
s to make it more general it's not
further hit only for the hidden you know
units so we would get a weight update
that is proportional to the rate of
change of the postsynaptic right it's
with the H theta H here and the prison
optic firing rate and this has a nice
property to when behaves very similar to
stvp I assume that most people you know
what M s 3p else but it's just a simple
learning rule that was observed at least
and some in biological systems so this
is data that taken from biological
experiments so it's learning rule that
if we have two neurons that prison optic
and the postsynaptic one and the prison
optic fires shortly before the
postsynaptic neuron fires the connection
is strengthened if we have it in the
different order so we have a post that
postsynaptic spiking present upticks
bites spikes we get a real decrease the
way between the neurons as a synaptic
right
how would this work with symmetric
weights I mean wouldn't this kind of
increase W IJ and decrease w ji
yeah we would assume that it's always
like we have some synaptic or have the
symmetric weights and always if we
update one the other would need to be
updated as well this would of course
kind of time average one is going to
fire before another more or less than
the other way otherwise usually this
isn't of course not in a symmetric
setting in this biological rule of
course this would not work
because if you have two neurons that you
connect them with a symmetric way maybe
you can tell me about it afterwards
because I'm not so much specialist about
two different forms that I would be
curious about okay this is like a
biological evidence so we have increased
it like this is a delta time difference
between the spikes and we have an
increase which is larger as closer both
signals are or decrease if it's in the
different order so now one can add
shortly think about why it should work
to write it down in this way of yeah
using the postsynaptic change rate of
change and the presynaptic firing rate
and this is easy to understand because
we could look at this blue dotted line
could be the prison optic spike and then
we have an increasing you could assume
to have an increasing postsynaptic fight
like chain rate of change this would
mean that since the rate is increasing
we have a higher probability to have
spikes after the
Prison uptick spike acute and as like
having it before so we also we have
performed simulations you know based on
spikes and see ya rate of change and we
saw that we get a the way debates get
like formal really similar pattern to
what was observed in biological foreign
biological experiments in data we saw
before I left Montreal Benjamin and Josh
I continued and yeah based on these
ideas and developed a mathematically bit
more beautiful frame like I would say
because they started with yeah
concatenating the energy and the loss
which is awaited on how much was some
parameter which says how much the output
neurons are influenced now by the from
the outside world so they could put this
all together and then got a got a
theorem saying that you when calculating
the gradient at a at a fixed point where
we don't have any pressure from the
outside is that this could be calculated
if we have we look at the fixed point
when we clamp the neurons to the target
a little bit and if we - so a gradient
of the new energy if we run the network
without any influence from the outside
and this would then be similar to await
update that looks like this and which is
really close to the heavier learning
rule so we would have so some firing
weights in the system where the output
is where we clamped the output neurons a
bit to the target to the shifted a bit
to the target direction depending on
this parameter better they don't let it
run to a fixed point collectors
parameters and have the same or same
values for the free system where we
don't influence a target this is the
heavy n would be that we really forced
the output to be the targets over for if
we would run that better run to infinity
this can also be seen as some kind of
symmetric version of STP which then
would take care for this symmetric
weight update so this makes this
approach a bit more beautiful so to
summarize what we know we have seen that
the update of the leak integrator neuron
model performs large Markov chain Monte
Carlo inference we saw that the valleys
and steps of inference when starting
from a fixed point correspond to back
propagation obviously an error with
respect to the states and we saw that we
can associate the connected weight
update to the yes STP which is also a
really nice property for future work I
would find it highly interesting to
think about how we could and super do
unsupervised learning in a more
plausible way and with respect to the
new insights that also like there's some
dendrites generate white tights right
that play out the role in learning it
would be interesting to see if we can
also how this influences a machine
learning system and I'm looking for what
you timothy leary crabs talk because
these things I think he presents some
ideas in this direction
references questions
[Applause]
so um it seems that if you want the
plasticity to operate after the network
has reached a fixed point what would
happen if plasticity were on during the
transient dynamics you mean before when
it's like it would learn all the time
like even if not in a in a fixed point
I'm not sure how it would be in the in
our simple simple system but in the
system of this equilibrium propagation I
think the applets could be seen as but
it's also start to move this fixed point
but it could be seen as a time
integrated update from moving from this
fixed point to a fixed point where the
output units shifted a little bit
can you give us some idea about the
power of this approximation to pick up
what kind of things it's not so
efficient like back propagation they I
think they reached we like it was equal
even propagation they reached 0 our
training error on amnesty but it was not
as efficient as it would be have been
worse simple people on your network and
back propagation so it's we are not it's
a goal of getting more efficient
learning algorithms yet and it's a proof
of concept that it at least can learn a
data center the Moodle directly like the
output state you mean needs to be need
to be something given from the outside
you mean yes yeah yeah we would have
something exactly we would have a system
that would have an external signal from
the outside yeah and like in the
supervised setting it's always like that
why do we have some input and when I get
some output which is somehow given from
the outside world but I yeah it's true
that it's not so clear how in a
biological system
this is shifting into the right
direction to the target would work
[Applause]